I think the the the immediate change is
I think the view of sterling which
already had already started to shift in
the last month or so you saw a definite
reaction and the tip and change in the
tone of the sterling rock a lot of
short-covering a lot of people who were
bearish on sterling of covering those
positions so I think there is a general
feeling that the election assuming it
goes according to plan and probably
reinforce a stronger sterling so I think
that's been the immediate consequence of
the of the united spent we saw yesterday
that rise in Sterling is predicated
largely on the assumption that the UK
will now get a softer brexit because
Teresa may will be less cowed by
hardline brexit er MPs it's the market
miss reading that or getting too carried
away with that I've heard both lines of
arguments on that there's one that would
be less capture will be less cowed by
the hardliners there's the other side
which is arguing quite the opposite that
in fact this will allow her to have a
hard-line view and not have to pander to
to maintain her majority so I think you
could argue it either way I think the
reality is Teresa may steers her own
ship and in doing that you know she will
carry on down the path that she is
already on and I think she genuinely
believes I think that she can negotiate
a good deal for the UK the best deal
that she can and it would be as hard or
as soft as as as is feasible to achieve
clearly that rise in sterling has also
hit the value of these big
multinationals of which there are plenty
in the footsie 100 who derive a lot of
their earnings from overseas how
unhelpful is that for equity investors
well it's one of those interesting
things about the UK market that the big
listed companies the footsie 100
companies there of course predominantly
overseas earners so peculiarly a weak
sterling is very good for them because
they translate a lot of overseas
earnings back to the UK so you always
see a sterling strengthens you tend to
see that their stock market sells off
and vice versa I think for most of the
list of sectors in the UK actually
they're not domestically oriented so the
immediate UK political environment
doesn't make very much difference to
them other than perhaps headline rates
of Taxation but at the margin really
there are news and Taxation is from
overseas so it hasn't really got a
direct impact certainly in the
short-term John McDonnell the Shadow
Chancellor accused mrs. may have going
to the country this morning because the
rise in inflation is eating into
disposable incomes potentially consumer
spending is going to slow down quite
sharply and with it the economy as a
whole has he got a point there I think
there is a risk of that I think we have
seen inflation tick up and you've seen
some of the public sector pay rises that
have been mooted so far this year
haven't kept pace with that inflation so
that does suggest that could be in some
sector as a real income squeeze so you
could make the case that there was a
little bit of political expediency in
going early before that economic bite
hits people's sentiment and at the
moment obviously their Conservative
Party is riding very high in the polls
so there's a lot of political expediency
about that but actually I don't think
that is the real reason that certainly
seems to me it's much more to do with
the timing of the brexit negotiations
and not wanting the potential
distraction of being quite a sensitive
and difficult transition period at the
same time as you're trying to run a
general election campaign which would be
the case if she didn't go early now so
you know I think it's probably much more
about the timing of that than it is
about this potential squeeze we might
see in the short term on real incomes
now investors like you have an awful lot
of geopolitical issues with which to
grapple right now North Korea Syria the
possibility of a far left or far right
president of France being elected where
does the UK election sit in that list of
concerns
nuki election actually I think fits
quite low down on that list because
markets are there's so much going on in
the political sphere there are so many
curveballs coming out of left field that
markets in a way becoming quite immune
the reaction periods are very very short
no to new events that are coming out so
I think short of a very major surprise
like a major configuration in North
Korea or something particularly
unexpected coming out of the French
particularly the first round of the
French presidential elections this
coming weekend I think actually markets
are tending to shrug off some of these
political factors
and in the grand scheme of things when
you look at where the UK fits and all of
that frankly markets don't think it's
very important it's quite far down the
list